the Joe Rogan experience so you're
calculating his movement yeah I'm not
doing it this way I'm doing it like
internal muscle marry right memory which
is your memory of fights and sparring
and knowing what you can do versus
knowing what you see him doing yeah and
just like it's like a dance so hard to
explain to people I don't understand why
you look at a guy and you like listen to
me that guy's gonna [ __ ] that guy up and
people go what are you talking about
listen to me that guy's gonna like when
Anderson Silva first fought Chris Leben
yeah I remember the odds were like real
close and I pulled a friend of mine
aside I said bet the house house on
Anderson he goes e-series I go bet the
house I go bet the house yeah I go this
guy's an assassin this is a different
thing you've seen a different thing I'm
telling you this is of this is one of
the rare the [ __ ] sky has to fall for
him to lose
no one knew that's the thing no one knew
who it was until that happened I had
watch all those cage warriors fire when
he was standing in front of Jorge Rivera
let him punch him in the face
he just rolling was as well as well
people don't understand this funny they
said ah [ __ ] casuals yes I like it a
lot of experts as well have casual
brains because they're like you know
Israel has no knockout power cuz he hand
this is silver in the face clean I'm
like you don't understand this Anderson
is playing the game where me and him are
playing this game so when I hit him I
didn't hit him clean I'm not trying to
hit him where he is
I'm trying to hit him where he's gonna
be hmm but then he knows that as well so
he did anticipate that and then pause
the distance is just right so it just
makes him there's a time I kicked him in
the face and I slowed it down to my
histogram doesn't want I'm just like my
toes you see my toes and Mowgli as for
like the top lip and I went I felt it
yeah so Nichkhun
will play in this game but I literally I
was trying to hit him where he's gonna
be but then he paused and then the punch
would just do so it looked cool yeah
look I didn't hit him clean right I did
like he just whipped playing this game
and people don't understand people
who've never fought they don't
understand that game you're playing yeah
it was beautiful me I love that fine
because I try to who's boring I was I
fought all iconic
that was I wish he had left after that
fight man cuz I wanted to be the one the
people yeah that was a great fight yeah
but this is people that don't have an
appreciation for movement and like what
it takes what it takes people don't know
[ __ ] about MMA no most people don't know
[ __ ] about everything exactly yeah I
mean there's a lot of people out there
that are experts yeah don't know [ __ ]
about what they're talking about
the thing about Anderson and you is
goddamn I would have loved to see that
fight when Anderson was 10 years younger
yeah you are a warrior out right now
I'll tell you how it goes how's it go
same way I went you know why why he's
never had someone do to him what he's
done to people hmm cuz then what I was
doing to him making him jump making him
do whenever he did this mm-hmm that's
all for gays E that's all you may see is
I I've used it a few times I mean you
know it means it's an interesting term
it was there was a limousine company in
New York and I started writing bad
checks and so those checks became Fugazi
checks it's fake
so with Italian yeah yeah it was it was
a limousine company called Fugazi
limousine so it's not a real word now
well it is it just became for gays yeah
yeah so this company started writing bad
checks so anytime that something's fake
its Fugazi uh-huh yeah there's something
new every day like boom oh yeah yeah
so whatever I'd like faints him or make
him jump or make him react you know like
I got you he'd like right driving hands
come 52 blocks right what it was he
didn't through his career fighting
really good fighters great fighters but
never an elite kickboxer yeah never an
elite world-class kickboxer like a world
championship caliber final of yourself
not a well not a kickboxer but
definitely some like you said good
fighters but the guys all the guys that
he beat of that error they couldn't last
in this air it's a different time now
the game has changed the game keeps
evolving and it like I say it's no
disrespect but it's just it's it's if
you had me in my prime
right now with my mom even in my prime
kind of in it how many now 27 do you
thirty I try rise likewise likewise but
um yeah it's just pretty much the game
over
inches a game of fake in the game of ha
gotcha
right and I do that better than him yeah
I feel that and dude this is a guy I've
loved and I've you know [ __ ] Gagnon
Gia's about him the whole [ __ ] career
like he's a [ __ ] he's wrong words yes
play but I know he's literally like a
fanboy Dover the guy is all career and
I've studied in him I knew what he was
gonna do before he do it like when he
tripped me I was getting up in my head I
was like okay here come they're flying
me and then whoop I did like literally I
pressed eject I was like get the [ __ ]
out of Dodge the way honestly I was I'm
not a he just have the case like at one
point even I hit him in the tummy I hit
him in the tummy and he touched me in
the coming and I was like he goes let me
try I was like no even when at one point
as well would he put his hands down and
not like we play in that game in this
right
I wouldn't stop doing that I threw my
hands up while I stopped doing that
there's no one on this [ __ ] planet if
you put your hands in and [ __ ] up that
I'll tell you stop doing that but no
hands now should not keep doing that but
whatever reason I said stop doing that
and I know why I said that that's why
that's a question I have to answer like
after I retire and see because people
were like oh did you hold back on and
I'm like [ __ ] no I almost I rocked him
in the first round and if I had dead in
him I was trying to I was trying to win
but yeah I still have love for the guy
and I respect the guy he might not feel
the same but he's some he's a gun yes
yeah konishi told me like i'ma get like
you beat let me know what to do he told
me like I said don't lose focus and
that's why I even right now like I said
form oh I'm like you know all the [ __ ]
is cool this victory tour you know
rating this [ __ ] around it's nice but I
want to work yeah to the mix champion on
the percent man was it weird being
across the cage from him knowing him
like only one more one moment there was
one moment and it was in a third round
and he went to the he's like come on it
puts his back against the fence is what
he that's a Bisping mm-hmm any fart
kicked him in the face come on okay and
they're like gonna set it and I won't
pause I was just stood out I'm gonna
wait to and it was maybe like seven
seconds but just a split second in there
dancers like holy [ __ ] I
fighting innocent Silva now this is my
time my back wasn't nice right here then
he came to the center of the cage and we
can't think going but yeah done fighting
with my god it's for moments like this
[ __ ] the bill its iconic moments that
you know like ollie over I'm Sonny
Liston yeah yeah pictures left at home
framed signed by Muhammad Ali Wow
yeah [ __ ] like the awesomeness for
someone some time and that's gonna be
framed almost so beautiful man and I
this is Rock Lee even something like
this some synchronicities that happen so
this is from this anime the first fight
I watched in this King Google this pull
it up Jamie what is it
Rock Lee vs. Gaara GA ara this is
episode 46 of Naruto and it was the
first fight I ever watch that got me
into the series and what is this anime
series Naruto I've only seen it online
it takes too long it's the 720 episode 4
kings
yeah 720 episodes yeah he said this bit
right here he takes the the weights off
he takes the weight off or you can watch
the highlights and then literally
there's some heavy-ass weights but he
[ __ ] up Gaara but I did the stance Rock
Lee normally does I did the stance that
he normally does in the weigh-ins and
Anacin stood there like Gaara he
probably doesn't even know what that is
well he just stood there like this and
[ __ ] like that it's a tied you to fight
it just like when life imitates art
without even trying you know what I mean
and I edited it I got some guys you know
shots of call crafts and Blackburn
effects they edited it for me to make it
look the same as this but literally yeah
[ __ ] like this jazz me oh man I'm
geeking out right now
[ __ ] nerd chatter John Jones I did
call you nerd yeah I know my feelings
[Laughter]
[Applause]